les énergies nous là sont indispensables
dans le cadre de du mix énergétique de
la France l'objectif était de passer la
part des énergies renouvelables à 23% et
nous en sommes à 19% aujourd'hui donc un
retard au niveau national nous sommes le
mauvais élève au niveau européen
on constate que selon les projets les
temps d'implantation sont de 5 à 10 ans
pour l'éolien en mer 5 ans pour les
parcs photovoltaïques donc il y a
énormément de procédures d'autorisation
diverses et parmi les principaux freins
il y a effectivement cette lourdeur la
longueur des contentieux etc mais il y a
aussi et surtout à mon sens la question
de l'acceptabilité le fait que ces
projets soient souvent imposés aux
populations locales aux élus locuses qui
sont beaucoup de concertations pour être
très clair et donc tout ça constitue
aggloméré et bien des freins importants
au développement des énergies
renouvelables donc c'est pour cette
raison qu'on a intégré un centre de
disposition sur pour répondre en tout
cas à ces problématiques
[Musique]
quand on a regardé le texte quand il est
arrivé il y avait une vingtaine
d'articles et il concernait quasi
exclusivement l'éolien en mer et le
photovoltaïque et nous avons décidé ici
au Sénat d'intégrer l'ensemble des
énergies renouvelables qui sont
indispensables sur ces également
d'innovation créativité il y a beaucoup
de startups beaucoup d'entreprises qui
travaillent sur ces questions et qui
proposent aujourd'hui des solutions
alternatives donc notre objectif c'était
d'ouvrir le champ des énergies
renouvelables le plus large possible et
donc on a intégré dans le texte voilà
toutes ces matières là qui permettront
demain de faire progresser les énergies
renouvelables dans le mix énergétique et
nous avons aussi mis un grand nombre
d'autres mesures sur l'autoconsommation
sur l'obligation pour les porteurs de
projets à ouvrir leur capital aux
citoyens au TPE PME mais aussi aux
collectivités locales on a élargi ce
cette possibilité là pour que les
acteurs locaux s'approprient réellement
soit l'initiative et s'approprie ensuite
les projets de différentes façons et
notamment avec une ouverture de capital
je pense qu'on a on a fait un texte qui
est plutôt
solide est complet sur l'ensemble des
énergies renouvelables et qui devrait
permettre d'accélérer enfin de
simplifier et d'accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
[Musique]